>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Tomoko Steen: Hello, everyone.
I'm Tomoko Steen at
the Science Technology
and the Business Division here
at The Library of Congress.
Today's speaker, we have a
prominent speaker, and this is part
of the celebration of Asian
Pacific American Heritage Month.
So the co-sponsorship is Library of
Congress Asian American Association.
I'm also Vice President
for that organization,
and this works very well.
A wonderful speaker, Asian American,
and a top speaker,
also in the Physics.
Today's speaker, Dr. Gong Ping
Yeh, am I pronouncing it okay?
Is a world-renowned high energy
Physicist, which his lecture today,
World Energy Transformation,
Asia and Beyond,
will talk about sustainable energy
and improving energy efficiencies.
So Dr. Yeh has been a high energy
Physicist at the Fermi National Lab
and he has been there since 1985,
so he has been doing a very
prominent research there,
as well as he's a member
of the Academia Sinica.
And he's running around the
world explaining his research,
while doing the research
at the same time.
I'm not sure how he manages it.
He has done Undergraduate Degree
at MIT and also a Master's Degree
at the Caltech and
also a Ph.D. at MIT
under Nobel Laureate
Gerald Friedman.
Dr. Friedman is really a pioneering
American Physicist, as well.
And we are lucky to have Dr. Yeh,
possible future Nobel Laureate,
and it's going to be an interesting
talk, beyond his physics background,
energy, so he covers biofuel
to solar energy to wind,
a variety of the energy,
and he is going to talk
about how we solve
this energy crisis.
So, without further ado, please
join me in welcoming Dr. Yeh.
[ Applause ]
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Good morning,
and thank you for the great honor
and special privilege of
sharing with you today one
of our greatest moments
in the human history.
We are transforming the world energy
to sustainable energy forever,
so this is really a special
moment of human history.
The 21st Century is the
Century of sustainable energy.
It's the greatest human challenge
and the greatest human
opportunity and endeavor.
The world energy consumption
is 15,000 gigawatts
or 15,000 billion watts,
giga means billion.
That's because we have seven billion
people on earth, on our blue planet,
and - wait a minute, this is
not working all of a sudden.
The forward isn't working.
>> The space bar?
>> Let me go back.
Okay, so because of
this 15,000 gigawatts,
that means we burn 10 billion
tons of carbon every year.
The seven billion people burn 10
billion tons of carbon every year.
What does that mean?
It means one million tons
every single hour of carbon
or equivalently four million
tons of CO2 every single hour.
Now that was simple arithmetic.
Now detailed scientific
studies show the same result,
its 10 billion tons every year or
1.1 million tons every single hour.
This is the cube of 100 meters on
each side, and that's a million tons
of carbon, okay, a million
tons of coal or a million tons
of oil, a million tons of water.
Now 100 meters is the length of a
football field plus an end zone.
So imagine the length of a football
field plus an end zone long,
the length of a football field plus
an end zone wide, and the length
of a football field plus an
end zone deep of oil or coal
and we burn that every single hour.
In one hour humans will have burned
another million tons of carbon.
The carbon comes from coal
and oil, gas and other things.
And at this moment China is
responsible for 27%, US 15%.
Okay, so to solve the world
energy challenge we also have
to solve the energy challenges
in China and India and the US
and every country worldwide.
The green Pope actually is
Pope Benedict, and he approved
and have installed in the
Vatican City solar panels
on one of the buildings.
And Pope Francis says we need to
care for our common home, okay?
So our Pope leaders are saying we
really need to solve this problem.
And recently the agreement in Paris
says every country should reduce CO2
emissions, that's the promise, every
country should reduce CO2 emissions.
The renewable energy percentage,
EU has a goal of 20% by 2020.
Well, by 2015 they already achieved
15%, this is EU, so that's good.
And the US is about 10%.
So that's what we should
do, at least have 20%
from renewable energies by 2020
and then we can do 50% by 2050,
so in this way we will solve
the world energy challenge.
So what we should do is as much
renewable energies as possible,
wind, solar, biofuels,
ocean, they're all good
and improve energy
efficiencies, also important.
For anybody or any country that
wants to use nuclear power,
nuclear power needs
fundamental changes.
Energy fuels development, so
where it's dark means they have no
electricity, where it's
developed there is electricity
and so lit up at night.
So 1.3 billion people on
earth have no electricity,
so about 600 million people in
Africa and 500, 600 million people
in Southeast Asia have
no electricity.
If we help them get electricity
we will completely help the world,
help Africa and Southeast
Asia and we help the world.
And the good news is we can do
this in the next 10, 20 years.
We will do this in
the next 10, 20 years.
This is the IEA Study
that shows about half
of Africa have no electricity.
It's a challenge, but it's
also a great moment for Africa.
We will do this in
the next 10, 20 years.
Cofean [Assumed Spelling] also
says in the Africa Progress Report
that by providing electricity we
will help Africa and the world.
The United Nations and the World
Bank also strongly say that we need
to provide sustainable energy to
everybody on earth by 2030 or so.
We want to thank the US
Government, the President,
the Congress for recently
having passed this Electrify
Africa Project.
It will help 50 million people
in Africa have electricity
for the first time, in
the next five years.
It's wonderful, thanks
to our Government.
The IEA says by 2035, in
the next 20 years or so,
the world really should spend about
$2 trillion per year on new energy.
Now with new technology
we can reduce this number,
so don't be scared
by the $2 trillion.
However, if anybody who
just wants to make money,
that means it's the
greatest opportunity,
right, $2 trillion per year.
Actually, the world now in the
last few years we have been able
to invest about $300 billion
every year on new energy,
renewable energy actually, okay?
So it's a great business
opportunity, as well.
China invested about $100
billion, US about $50 billion,
India $5 billion, okay
- India $10 billion,
sorry, and Africa $5 billion.
It also means jobs.
In 2014 there were 7.7 million
jobs related to renewable energies.
In the US alone was 724,000 jobs.
Even Saudi Arabia says by 2050 only
about 15% of their energy will be
from fossil and it's new fossil
because the known ones
will have been used up,
it'll be new fossil,
15% of the energy.
The rest, 85% comes from some kind
of nuclear and solar and wind.
This is Saudi Arabia.
Now just last month
Saudi Arabia announced,
the King announced a new Saudi
vision 2030 and they want to
and they need to transform
Saudi Arabia economy away
from dependence on oil.
The International Renewable Energy
Agency Headquarters is in Abu Dhabi.
Now that's very interesting.
The International Renewable
Energy Agency Headquarters
in the oil country.
Okay, according to IRENA the world
renewable energy capacity now is
about 2,000 gigawatts.
Of the 15,000 that we consume,
2,000 now is from renewable energies
or at least the capacity is.
So hydro is most of it, but
wind and solar are coming up.
And last year alone the world
installed 35 gigawatts of hydro
and 63 gigawatts of
wind and 47 gigawatts
of solar in one year alone.
That's probably equivalent
to electricity
from 50 new nuclear power plants.
So from the renewables now
every year we can add equivalent
to 50 new nuclear reactors
of electricity.
So the world wind power capacity now
is 430 gigawatts, and we can add 50,
60 gigawatts per year easily, okay?
So last year the world
added 63 gigawatts.
And China alone added 32 gigawatts,
about half of the world's wind power
was added last year was in China.
Some other countries could
add a lot more, much more.
The US did pretty well, so
the US added 8.6 gigawatts.
This is the total, in
China, total wind power
in China is 145 gigawatts,
and in the US 75 gigawatts.
So this is the distribution.
So China, Asia is doing well,
but it's mostly in China.
The rest of Asia could do much more.
And the US is doing well.
Solar energy, if we cover
1% of the world's land
with solar panels it could provide
30,000 gigawatts, twice the amount
of energy consumed by humans, okay?
So this is in Japan, and
when I fly between Tokyo
and Taipei I see this outside.
This was built in one year,
70 megawatts by one company
in one year, can build this.
Actually, many stadiums in
the world, including the US,
have solar panels on
top, and this one is
in Taiwan it's powered
10% by solar panels.
And when the stadium is not being
used the electricity can be used,
put onto the grid.
Sports stadium are a good place
to put solar panels, okay?
So the solar power is
expected to grow quickly
in the next five years
in many countries.
By 2020 the world should have
about 400 gigawatts of solar panel.
So China is adding a lot of solar
panels, so is the US, Japan, India.
Actually, an easier way
is just solar hot water,
and even in Minnesota
they have solar hot water
in the downtown St. Paul, okay?
The easiest way to use solar
energy is just solar hot water,
it's more efficient,
it's about 50% efficient.
So the world has 400 gigawatts
of solar thermal heating.
China alone in 2015 added
14.9 gigawatts of hydro,
32 gigawatts of wind,
18 gigawatts of solar.
So actually China is now the world
leader of renewable energies.
Unfortunately, China also added
six gigawatts of nuclear power
and 71 gigawatts of coal.
We need to change that.
Japan, Prime Minister Koizumi, put
into law, it's called Cool Biz.
So when you go to Japan June
to September you don't
have to wear a suit.
So they raised the
temperature a little bit,
just by that alone they saved
electricity 1% in Japan.
Now after March 11th the 54
reactors is reduced, were shut down,
and now only two are operating.
And Cool Biz became Super Cool Biz,
now from May until October 31st
when you go to Japan you don't
have to wear a suit by law, okay?
Now also in the last three years
Japan added 27 gigawatts of solar
and then Japan is in the process
of electricity deregulation,
so that's great, the open market
instead of just monopolies.
And Japan has tremendous, has good
wind power potential, as well.
Japan should be able to add
tens of gigawatts wind power.
For example, Japan, South Korea
and Taiwan all have tremendous
offshore wind power potential,
and these countries should
use offshore wind power
as soon as possible.
Taiwan, the people of Taiwan
just elected a new President
and new Congress, it
actually is the Green Party.
So Taiwan, starting May 20th,
is going to greatly change its
energy policies, that's great.
South Korea also has a national
statement policy to achieve 11%
by 2035 of energy coming
from renewables.
We should be able to do better
than this, with new technology
and some thinking we should
be able to do better than 11%.
Even in Southeast Asia
there have been discussion
of towards low carbon
by 2050 in Asia Pacific.
Now IEA Study announced last year,
they said if we just do business
as usual this is what
it's going to look like.
So although the renewables
is increasing gas,
oil and coal increased even more,
but this is business as usual
and I don't - I'm sure that we're
not going to be doing business
as usual, so this will be changed.
For example, Southeast
Asia also has lots of sun,
especially in the dry season.
They should just be
using solar, okay?
So for all of you that are from
Southeast Asia please tell them
to use solar and there
are other things.
For example, the Pacific
Island nations,
until recently they only had
a small amount of renewables,
but because they heard about, hey,
wait a minute, the solar power is
so good now, so they are
completely changing to renewables,
all the Pacific Island countries.
In Hawaii, Hawaii says they're
going to have 100% of their energy
from renewables by
2045 or 70% by 2030.
Until a few years ago 98% of
Hawaii's energy was imported oil,
okay, so Hawaii is
completely changing.
It's wonderful, it's
going to be clean Hawaii.
And Okinawa and Hawaii
are very close,
they have a very close
relationship, and recently thanks
to Ambassador Caroline Kennedy
the agreement between Hawaii
and Okinawa is extended,
so that's great.
Most people know for lighting
we should just switch to LEDs
because LEDs are at least
five times more efficient
than incandescent lights, so we
should all change to LEDs as much
as possible, saves
electricity and it's brighter.
And our Administration,
our leaders push
for doubling the fuel efficiency
of cars and that's great,
the more we do the better.
In the US there are 764 companies
or governments or organizations
that are already 100% powered by
renewable energies, including Intel,
Microsoft, Apple, City of Dallas
and the City of Washington,
D.C. And the NHL, the NHL has
the 100% renewable energy credit.
And Carnegie-Mellon
University, for example.
See, so if you want
to do it you can,
you can have your electricity
100% from renewables now.
Maybe The Library of Congress
can be 100% powered by it, okay?
So US added 75 gigawatts
of wind power last year.
We can easily do this again.
Oh, sorry, the total
is 75 gigawatts.
The Midwest has tremendous
wind power potentials,
and this is the wind capacity.
Actually, Texas has 17 gigawatts
in wind power, Texas is the leader
of wind power in the US as
far as the amount installed.
But Iowa, the small State, actually
has the most wind power per capita.
So 31% of Iowa's electricity last
year came from wind power, okay?
But the US, even including
Iowa, we have only installed 1%
of our potential, so wind power
in the US can be much more.
We probably could be,
the US probably could be
powered by wind power alone.
The former Secretary of the Interior
says the wind power off the East
Coast offshore could
replace most of the coal
that we use, just the
offshore alone.
Now when we talk about renewable
energies there's always a question
about the electricity storage.
Well, there's several ways, for
example, you can use battery
or you could use renewable
energy to make hydrogen,
or you can use pump hydro, you pump
up the water into a higher level
and then when you need it
you use the water, okay?
So, for example, this is just
using battery in the Ohio,
it's 40 megawatts, it's doable.
You can store electricity
if you wanted.
So Tesla is spending,
investing $5 billion
into this new giga factory
to make batteries, okay?
By doing so the more the
world produces batteries,
the lower the price will become.
So this is the projection,
right now it's more expensive,
but the more we use it the lower
the price it will be, okay?
So batteries is one
of the solutions.
Another one is to use wind or
solar power to make hydrogen,
so the National Renewable
Energy Lab is studying this,
but actually it's already
done in Germany.
This is using wind
power to make hydrogen,
and then you can use hydrogen
whichever way you want it.
The US has also tremendous
solar power potential.
Again, this is downtown
Minnesota, convention center on top
of convention - actually, on top
of convention centers is a
great places for solar panels.
So Orlando Convention Center also
has megawatts of solar power.
Or airports, even airports are great
places for putting solar panels.
The US Military is
actually the leader
of renewable energies
in the US, okay?
It's better to use solar panels
than deliver fuel, for example.
Actually, US Military also has
this net zero policy for US bases,
the US Military would like US
Military bases to be independent of,
to be energy independent.
So we all know that the
solar panels have been coming
down in price dramatically
every year.
So in the last year the new
installations of energy in the US,
39% is actually wind power and
about 29% was gas and 29% was solar.
Last year the new energy added was
about one-third each
wind, solar and gas.
No other sources.
Okay, so this is the
US solar installations.
Because the price is going
down, so you see the quick rise
of solar power in the US,
also, but it's a quick rise
of solar power worldwide,
actually, okay,
because the price keep coming down.
And this is the ranking
of solar power by state.
California is by far the leader,
about half of the US solar
power is now in California.
Amazingly, North Carolina
and Massachusetts are
also among the top.
Now the Sunshine State,
if the Sunshine State used more
solar power they can save billions
every year, and also New Mexico.
Another great place
to put solar panels
and the solar charging is
just parking lots, okay?
All parking lots pretty much
are a potential great places
for installing solar power
and electrical charging.
And some viewers even
provide free solar charging.
Now FedEx, UPS, DHL all have
electric trucks for delivery.
US Postal Service seems
to be a great place,
great to have the US
Postal trucks electric,
they could be powered
by the sun or the wind.
They don't go very far every day,
okay, so it's easy to charge them.
So US Postal trucks should
all be electric, I think.
Also, school buses, they don't
go very far either every day,
so most of them are
just sitting around
and travel a short
distance every day.
Perfect for using electric.
Actually, all transportation
could be electric, buses,
boats, golf carts, ideal.
The US has already more than 30,000
charging stations and there are apps
on the internet, web, you can find
out where the charging stations are.
And actually I think smart cars
should have them on the board,
on the dashboard, and
it'll just tell you, hey,
you are 20% remaining
electricity, you should turn right
and go and get charged up.
So electrically charging up electric
cars is also not a problem now.
in Estonia, for example, they have
a couple hundred fast charging
stations, so you can just charge
it up and it's 100% renewable,
90% of it just from the wind, okay?
And this has happened in many
countries, also, the Netherlands
and Germany even where there's
not really much sun actually,
but they have a lot of solar power.
For example, a small startup company
in Chicago is starting 3,000
solar charging stations in Jordon
and are exporting to
other countries.
Now there's another thing
called supercapacitors,
and it works like lightning.
If we want to charge
the electric vehicles,
you wanted to charge
them fast, right?
You don't want it to take too long.
So you want some fast
way of charging it.
Well, capacitors charge and
discharge very fast, like lightning,
but you need large areas to do this,
so they use [inaudible]
material to have huge surface.
So a small amount, a gram
of [inaudible] material has the
surface of a football field.
So then you're going to
have electric buses charged
up at one bus station in 30
seconds and enough electricity
to go another couple bus stops.
So it goes to one, and the
next bus stop it gets charged
up again in 30 seconds.
It goes to another stop and gets
charged up again in 30 seconds.
So you can charge your buses
this way, as well, all electric.
And Korea is making
progress in this.
And also there are some electric
buses in Italy and other countries.
Biofuels, there's wood pellets,
some countries use it and it's good,
at least close to carbon neutral,
so it's also fast growing.
Ethanol and biodiesel
are also growing.
And recently, just recently in the
last years, now you can make ethanol
from cellulosic ethanol
from grass or corn stover.
So you don't have to
make it from food,
you don't want to make it from food.
In fact, United Airlines and others
have already started using bio jet
fuel, okay, and this has been
tested by Boeing, Airbus, Military.
So in the future when we need more
jet fuel we can use bio jet fuel.
For hydro, hydro is actually
good if you do it right.
It don't hurt the environment,
but then you can provide
constant electricity.
So hydro is actually
good if you do it right.
So the world is also building
hydro and its good, for example,
for Africa, as well,
and South America.
This one shows the cost of
electricity, 2010 and 2014.
You see that the prices is coming
down even between 2010 and 2014,
and wind power, hydro, geo,
bio they're already the
level or cheaper than coal.
The lowest price electricity in
the US now is actually wind power.
So the percentage of world
electricity about 22% is
from renewables now of which about
4% of the world's electricity now is
from wind and only about
1% is from the solar,
but it's growing, those are growing.
There's also ocean energy in various
forms, in waves, currents, okay?
So remember the energy is
proportional to the density,
and the water density is
about 800 times air density,
so even a small turbine in the water
can provide you lots of it actually.
Regarding nuclear power, we all
know about the nuclear crisis,
there are about 400
reactors in the world
and they provide 336 gigawatts,
which is about 10.8% or 11%
of the world's electricity.
So the 400 reactors in the
world provide about 11%
of the world's electricity.
That means the 400 reactors
in the world provide 2.6%
of the world's energy.
So all the reactors in the world
reduce carbon emissions by 2.6%.
If we turn them all off the carbon
emissions will go up by 2.6%.
This shows the startup
and the shutdown
of nuclear reactors in the world.
The average age of all reactors
in the world is 29 years
and the average age of the
99 reactors in the US is 35.
They are designed for 40 years.
So it is expected that the number
of reactors in the world will go
down in the next 10, 20 years.
In the next 10 years about
100 will be decommissioned.
In the next 20 years about
200 will be decommissioned.
The single place that's
increasing the number
of nuclear reactors is China.
So nuclear power has five
fundamental challenges - safety,
nuclear waste, weapons
proliferation,
the cost, and sustainability.
As I said earlier, the world
should use as much renewable energy
as is possible, but the
nuclear power if anybody wants
to use it it has to be changed.
This is a molten salt reactor,
it was done in the
Oak Ridge National Lab
in the '60s, actually also '50s.
It uses liquid instead of solid
fuel, so you can drain a liquid
if anything happens or you can
just put a small amount of liquid
in there at a time, so
you reduce the probability
of nuclear problem, safety problem.
And also if you use thorium, thorium
doesn't do anything by itself,
you have to give it neutrons
for the process to go.
To use thorium for energy you
have to provide the neutrons.
You can stop the neutrons and then
the process will stop so it's safe.
If we want to use more nuclear power
we have to make sure it's 100% safe.
There's a study in Japan that shows
that if Fukushima were
using thorium instead
of uranium there would have been
no other problems except some heat
to get rid of.
You wouldn't have the
radiation problem,
you wouldn't have the explosion, you
wouldn't have any of these problems.
Also, because it's LM90
instead of 92, okay,
it's more difficult to make bombs.
You could still do it, but it's
more difficult to make bombs
and if you make bombs with it
it would be more detectable
because there will be
some uranium 232 there
and it will give you signals, that
people are trying to make bombs.
And because it's LM90 the nuclear
waste amount will be 10,000 times
smaller, so instead of 10 times you
get a kilogram, and the half-life
of that is about hundreds
of years instead of millions
or hundreds of thousands of years.
So you also have much less
manageable nuclear waste problem
just by doing, just by
switching to thorium.
So, of course, it's also
a form of nuclear energy,
so a handful of it has the same
energy as 230 train cars of coal.
A small amount of thorium
can provide the same energy
as 230 train cars of coal.
So it has lots of energy.
And the world can already have
six million, seven million tons
of thorium at the very low price,
so there's a tremendous amount
of thorium available worldwide.
So if we switch to thorium we
can provide the world energy
for thousands of years safely
and very little nuclear waste
and less problem of nuclear weapons.
Now so China wants
this and they know
that they need technical assistance,
so they actually asked the US
to help, so the US is
actually partnering with China
on this molten salt and
thorium energy technologies.
India says, hey, we have lots
of thorium, we should switch
to thorium power, as well.
So actually India already
has designed,
completed design of thorium reactor.
And actually in the US there
are a whole bunch of companies
that are doing development
for molten salt reactors
and thorium energy.
So UK a few months ago announced
they are investing 250 million
pounds over the next five
years to develop advanced
or a new type of reactor.
In the US the DoE also in the last
few months announced the US is also
investing into two companies
to develop this new reactor
in the next few years.
In fact, the US DoE also established
a new department or agency
to help bring about this
new technology faster.
Yes?
>> On your previous slide
it mentions pebble bed.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
>> Is that different
compared to molten salt?
>> Gong Ping Yeh: It's a different
form, it's pebbles, it's different
from - the question is is pebble
bed different from the molten salt?
Yes, it is.
The molten salt is liquid and
the pebble bed is little pebbles,
but it's some uranium and then some
thorium together, blanket, and okay?
Now thorium, okay, the neutron
cross sections or the probability
of thorium doing something
varies according to the energy
of the neutrons that are given.
Most reactors operate in
the lower energy region
and this is what it is, okay?
The nuclear reactors operate at
this lower energy region, actually.
But if you go to a higher energy
then you can actually break apart,
called fission, real fission,
break apart the nucleus.
Actually, it's typical
of all heavy elements.
In the lower energy region
the reactors operate in here,
but for thorium and
the 238 if you go
to higher energies you can
do the complete fission,
break up the nucleus.
Now this may sound a
little complicated,
but I'll explain it to
you, it's very easy.
So Europe has a project to
say let's use an accelerator
to produce the neutrons and to have
thorium energy or other things.
Well, in fact, the Oak Ridge
National Lab already has an
accelerator, that's pretty good.
We need to make it more
intense, but it's pretty good.
And Oak Ridge has been using
this accelerator for some time.
Europe is building a new
accelerator as we speak right now.
So this is their schedule.
It will be done in
the next few years.
And China also has a plan to
build accelerator driven system,
and India also.
And Russia says, hey, we have an
old accelerator, we can convert it.
So you see several
countries want to do this.
In fact, in the US the DoE
sponsored and there's a statement,
accelerators for America's future,
accelerators can shrink tumors,
produce clean energy and
reduce nuclear waste.
Now in the US we actually invented
using protons or heavy ions
to treat tumors, also
neutron therapy, okay?
This was built by Fermilab
and this was at Fermilab.
So this is neutron
therapy, for example,
tumors and you just shoot neutrons
at it and destroy the nucleus
of the tumor cells and
you cure the person.
Okay, this is a large tumor
here, these is a hand,
so there's a huge tumor and
you just shoot neutrons at it,
two minutes a day,
three times a week
and four weeks later
you cure the person.
So it's neutron therapy, use
neutrons to break up the nucleus.
Well, neutron therapy can
solve the nuclear problem.
We use the nuclear reactors,
these are the wastes,
the high level nuclear waste.
And if you don't treat it,
if you just bury it underground
it can last for millions of years.
This will be the radiation
for a million years
if you just bury it underground,
if you don't actually treat it.
Even the former Energy
Secretary, Steven Chu,
said nobody has really solved
the nuclear waste problem.
Well, we actually could do it.
Now this I showed you earlier, that
if you have MeV neutrons or 10,
20 MeV neutrons you can break up
the nucleus of heavy elements.
The ordinary reactors operate in
this range, but there's a type
of reactor that's been talked
about and being developed,
it's called fast reactors,
they operate in this range.
But if you use the accelerator
to provide the neutrons it's
even higher, so it's even better,
and you can absolutely control it,
you can turn it off
anytime you want.
So absolute safety.
So there have been US studies, also,
that says you can transmit
nuclear waste.
These are fission products, you
can actually break them apart.
And this is just using
the fast reactors.
If you use the accelerator
system it'll be even better.
In Japan they have studied this.
See, again, using the accelerator,
and this is nuclear waste,
they can use nuclear waste as
fuel to produce electricity,
at the same time destroy
the nuclear waste.
So Japan estimates they need
about four of these systems
because they have 40 reactors now.
And you can shorten the half-life of
nuclear waste from millions of years
to thousand or hundred or even
15 years if you use the neutrons
to break up the nuclear waste.
The European study also says
if you use the accelerator,
provide fast neutrons, you can
reduce the amount of nuclear waste
and you can shorten the
half-life of the nuclear waste.
So because of development
in the accelerators now we
can have this accelerator,
we can build it now.
It's available, if we just build
these accelerators we can take care
of these problems.
The technology we have now.
Okay, so we can and we will
solve the world energy challenge
through renewable energies
as much as possible,
improve energy efficiencies, and if
anybody wants or any country wants
to use nuclear power we need
to change nuclear power
fundamentally, totally.
By doing this we can have 20% of the
world energy coming from renewables
by 2020, 30% by 2030, and
more than 50% by 2050.
We will transform the world
energy in the next decades.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Tomoko Steen: Any questions?
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes?
>> Is the concept of
energy from fusion,
is that considered a dead end then?
>> Gong Ping Yeh: So the question
is is the concept of fusion
as energy is it - what's the status?
Well, the experts of fusion says
it's probably 50 years away.
So we can't wait that long.
We will solve the world
energy challenges by then.
Yes?
>> What about hydrogen?
>> Gong Ping Yeh: What
about hydrogen?
The hydrogen, we've been talking
about that, as well, for decades,
and the thing is to deploy it,
well, you need hydrogen stations,
you need hundreds of thousands
of these hydrogen stations.
So it's coming along.
Japan, especially, has been
promoting hydrogen, but it's going
to take decades when it comes.
It's one of the forms.
I showed you earlier that we can
use wind power and solar power
to produce hydrogen, then
that's absolutely clean.
If you just get the hydrogen
from natural gas it's not
all that clean, right?
You're still using natural gas, but
you could do that using solar power
and wind power to make the hydrogen.
So it's coming, but it will
be one of the solutions.
Yes?
>> I want to say that sometimes
we go to the beach by Ocean City
and so along the highway this summer
for the first time I
saw a solar installation
that I think is maybe 40 or
60 acres, and to think of that
in Maryland was just a
different thing for me.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
>> Thinking of Arizona
and California,
but to see that in Maryland
it really was a real thing
that was happening,
it was different.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
Thank you.
So your statement was that it's nice
to see solar panels
even in Maryland.
>> Right.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
Now when I showed that even
Washington, D.C., we use -
the Government of Washington,
D.C. use a lot of wind power.
And solar power, actually
the entire,
almost the entire US has good
potentials for solar power, okay?
So in the list that I showed you
Massachusetts uses more solar power
than Florida.
So really we need to get
Florida to use solar power.
It can save Florida billions
of dollars every year,
instead of buying coal or
buying oil, other energies,
Florida can save billions of
dollars by switching to solar power.
Any other questions?
Yes?
>> In your presentation
you discussed briefly
about how you might be able to take
care of energy needs in Africa.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
>> Within 10, 15 years.
>> Now similar issues are also
relevant in South Asia ...
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
>> ... where high proportions
of families rely
on solid fuel, like cooking.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
>> They're looking at populations
that rely on solid fuel for cooking.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
>> And they're dying to get moved
to clean energy, but it's easier
for to take care of
their energy needs.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
>> Can you say a little
more about your thought
on how you might be able
to take care of Africa,
as well as in South Asia?
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Okay.
>> The needs are for
solid fuel for cooking.
I'm looking at women's -
the resources that women
have to put together.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
Thank you.
So the question and comment is
we can potentially help Africa
and Southeast Asia ...
>> South Asia.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: ...
South Asia move to renewable
energy, especially solar,
in the next 10, 20 years.
So how best to do this, right?
Yes, so as I said earlier, that
the Africa and Southeast Asia
about 600 million people in
Africa and about 500 million,
600 million people in Asia
and India have no electricity
and they burn solid fuels.
So what we need to do is to let
people know, let the Government
and the people in South Asia and
Africa - Africa has so much sun,
okay, or the countries, those
central Asia countries also,
so many countries in the
world, including South Asia,
they have so much solar
power potential.
And it's probably because they don't
know about it or they don't know how
to finance it, that's
slowing them down.
So there are different models
to finance this, you know.
Solar City is a great example,
in the US, when people say, oh,
solar panels are too expensive, they
say, oh, you don't have to buy it,
just lease it, let me just put solar
panels on top of your roof, okay?
And then 10 years from
now it is yours,
and you pay electricity
lower than what you pay now.
We'll put solar panels on top of
your roof, you pay electricity lower
than what you pay now, and then 10
years from now the system is yours.
You get your electricity for free.
So we need to explain to
people the different models
in adding renewables.
Most people in the world don't know
and even the Governments don't know
and they don't know how
to do it or they don't -
sometimes they need some
help, also, but we can do it,
we can do it in the
next 10, 20 years.
>> Tomoko Steen: Any more questions?
I have one question.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes?
>> Tomoko Steen: Could you
tell me the differences
between an accelerator,
small nuclear reactor
and the big nuclear reactor?
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Okay,
so for the small ones
if you want just 50 megawatts
or 100 megawatts you don't
need an accelerator to do that,
you don't want that because
an accelerator costs some.
So for small ones just
through molten salt
or switching to thorium, okay?
There you need to reprocess to
get the neutrons to continue.
So for those small ones
you need the reprocessing.
For the accelerator one you
don't need the reprocessing,
you now have the neutrons
anytime you want
so you don't need the
reprocessing, okay?
So that's the beauty
of the accelerators,
but for the accelerators
it's better for large scale,
like the gigawatts scale.
So for the large reactors, large
system, use the accelerators,
but for small ones
all over the place,
all over the world use molten salt
thorium, you still have a little bit
of waste, you need reprocessing
to get the neutrons, that's all.
>> Tomoko Steen: Price?
>> Gong Ping Yeh: You want
me to give you a cost?
Okay, is this recorded?
[laughter] Okay, now because you're
now doing a much safer system,
an absolutely safe system,
so you don't need five different
layers of safety protections.
So the cost is actually lower
than your nuclear reactors now.
So the average cost of a gigawatts
reactor now in the world is
about $5 billion, $6 billion.
If you change to the new system
maybe $2 billion, $3 billion.
You actually lower the cost.
Yes?
>> Just to clarify, are you saying
that the thorium reactor has less
stringent [inaudible] requirements?
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes, it's safe.
>> I just wanted to
make sure I understood.
>> Gong Ping Yeh: Yes, it's
safe and it's less waste,
so you don't need all those
extra five layers of protection
that are even not good enough.
Yes, that's what I'm
saying, it's safe.
And for nuclear power we need
to solve those five challenges -
safety, nuclear waste, weapons,
cost and sustainability.
We want to be able to use it for
thousands of years, not 100 years.
Okay. Thank you.
>> Tomoko Steen: I'd
like to thank Dr. Yeh,
could we have a hand
of applause for him?
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.